tesla bondi de plus de 15% en bourse en
réaction à des bons résultats financiers
bien meilleurs que prévu qui ont été
annoncés hier après la fermeture des
marchés
la valeur en bourse de tesla dépasse
maintenant general motors
imaginez tesla surpris les analystes en
annonçant des profits à son troisième
trimestre la construction de la nouvelle
usine en chine va plus rapidement que
prévu et la production du nouveau
véhicule de l'entreprise le modèle y est
aussi en avance prospective sur tesla
avec daniel breton consultant
l'électrification des transports il est
dans nos studios de trois rivières
daniel breton bonsoir bonsoir
comment vous expliquer ce résultat
inattendu de tesla bas inattendu je
dirais pour ceux qui suivent testa de
moins prêt mais à ses pêcheries
prévisible parce que on voit que les
choses avancent plus vite que prévu
alors qu'il est moche dans le passé vous
avez souvent habitué à prendre du retard
parce qu'on voit et que l' usine à
shanghai la construction et termine en
avance sont déjà dans les tests
donc ça veut dire que il va y avoir une
production de test à partir de la chine
bientôt ensuite de saubens les ventes de
modèles 3 sont entrés d'écraser
littéralement la concurrence un peu
partout dans le monde dont aux états
unis et la mode elle y dont vous parliez
à l'instant ça c'est un véhicule qui
risque de faire très mal à la
concurrence parce qu'en fait ils vont
être tout seul dans le créneau des vus
s1000 segment electric a pris jeudi
raisonnable
cette vue est le modèle y oui ça va être
un véhicule jusqu'à sept passagers mais
qui va se vendre au prix grosso modo de
9,4 d'un service bien équipé vous est
que ça risque de faire mal
ça risque de faire mal parce que ce sera
déjà un véhicule très efficace sur le
plan électrique 1 et 2 c'est que la
concurrence est pas rendu là c'est à
dire que pour le moment il si on regarde
les grands constructeurs généralistes
comme toyota honda hyundai nissan chez
terra personnes parmi une offre de v ux
100% électrique
ils ont il ya mitsubishi avec un virus
hybride rechargeable 35 km d'autonomie
toyota s'en vient avec un rav4 hybride
rechargeable qui devrait avoir autour de
50 km d'autonomie et là avec
le modèle y on parle de 3 500 km
d'autonomie
donc on est dans une autre ligue
complètement et il ya une demande vous
savez pour les us
la demande ne se dément pas donc je suis
persuadé que autant le modèle 3 vont
habiller je pense que modèle y vendent
encore mieux à cause la demande pour les
vives est-ce que ça m'est donc beaucoup
de pression sur les autres constructeurs
absolument absolument à tel point que
l'on voit des annonces qui sont faites
au salon de tokyo savant de saint gilles
il va y avoir des annonces faites
justement par différents constructeurs
même mazda se joint à la parade il reste
à peu près juste le constructeur mazda
qui n'avaient pas de propositions de
véhicules électriques
donc c'est clair que tu t'étais de
l'initiative ou du leadership de hyland
masque on en serait absolument pas rendu
là en matière de véhicules électriques
tesla développe aussi en europe des
slaves écouter ils vont annoncer qu'on
sait pas quand même bientôt apparemment
l'implantation d'une usine dans un pays
d'europe qui va gagner le gros lot dans
le fond c'est la question très rare de
voir ça
bref je pense que l'avenir s'annonce
fort intéressant pour tesla et puis pour
l'électrification des transports en
général mais au québec québec travaille
à développer la fabrication de batteries
au lithium ont bien souvent de lithium
ici quelles sont les démarches avec
tesla est ce qu'on est ce qu'on est en
démarchage avec tesla ben écoutez si
drôle que vous disiez ça parce que
lorsque j'étais moi même responsable la
stratégie d'électrification des
transports
j'avais eu des discussions avec des des
hauts dirigeants tesla j'ai même eu une
discussion avec hélène masque sur le
sujet on dit écoutez nous on a une
expertise en un centre de recherche qui
s'appelle lyrique avec monsieur karim
sahib que vous connaissez sur l'avenir
de la batterie de voiture électrique
à l'époque évidemment ils voulaient
patron de répondre parce que vous pouvez
vous imaginer que la quantité de
d'endroits de pays qui courtisent tesla
c'est pas ça qui manque ouais moi ce que
j'ai semblé comprendre c'est que sous le
gouvernement libéral les cadrages les
initiatives ont été moins présents avec
le nouveau gouvernement monsieur legault
avec monsieur facebook est bonne il
semble vouloir relancer les discussions
moi je trouve ça extrêmement intéressant
parce que on a plein d'atouts on
appelait d'entreprises québécoises qui
sont entrés 2
faire du québec un leader n'a
l'électrification des transports mais
l'on nomme des politiciens des pays des
gouvernements est ce que tesla se
développe dans le fond à coup de
subventions gouvernementales paraît
comme à peu près tous les autres
constructeurs automobiles encore je
donne je sais qu'ils mangent et m
c'est absolument écouter il ya des
subventions il ya des crédits d'impôts
il ya toutes sortes d'initiatives qui se
font de part et d'autre à travers le
monde pour attirer des grands
constructeurs écouter les emplois
manufacturiers sont des emplois d'abord
qui sont payants généralement ce qui
fait que tout le monde veut chez eux
donc
et c'est un jeu qui joue aussi bien
d'ailleurs d'en mieux d'aviation on le
voit loyalistes subventions sont
clairement là donc je pense qu'ils
jouent le même jeu que les autres
constructeurs
qu'est ce qui est à surveiller chez
tesla à partir de maintenant là on
parlait du modèle y met dans les
prochaines années on surveille quoi chez
tesla la camionnette en bon québécois le
péquin wissant vient pick up électrique
de tesla qui devrait dévoiler dans je
pense que ce tome en novembre
et puis le semi-remorque le test la
chimie dont la production en quantité
limitée va commencer on en 2020 donc si
vous ajoutez ça aux modèles y l'usaid en
chine + usines en europe écoutez je sais
pas au ski pendant qu'on dormait
monsieur basque et il y aura sans doute
des tesla au salon de véhicules
électriques en fin de semaine sainte qui
s est absolument donc on a notre salon
du véhicule électrique de
saint-hyacinthe 25 26 27 octobre au
centre bmo saint-hyacinthe où il va y
avoir en fait
l'assemblée annuelle du club de cela
québec donc il va y avoir des centaines
de tests qui vont être là en plus
évidemment des véhicules des autres
fabricants et de plusieurs
manufacturiers de véhicules low
québécois par exemple lyon n'oserait
saeco tourner
févry carbone québécois donc ils vont
une place pour les québécois
prépondérante au salon du véhicule
électrique de 500 daniel breton remercie
beaucoup
ça me fait plaisir